okay so imagine if a major media company
went big into twitch I'm talking
investing tons of money making 50 hours
of content basically launching a mini TV
channel on Twitch
it would be huge it would be a
game-changer well all that actually
happened but you didn't hear about any
of it why because it exploded in less
than a day in the dumbest way I've ever
heard of
[Music]
all right before we get into it I want
to remind you guys that we have a tips
line is there a story that you think we
need to cover on don't at me well just
send us an email and let us know and
don't forget to sub to the channel so
that you know when that video goes a lot
all right so again this is the story of
a twit channel that blew up in a matter
of hours
after going alive and did so for the
dumbest reasons I've ever heard of it
started with this French media company
called WA BD a group which is an
extremely French name but whatever
anyway they launched this show called
the live on twitch YouTube mixer pretty
much everything that you can stream live
on the idea was to basically have this
live TV channel on twitch so from 5:00
p.m. to midnight every day they would
stream my program it would be hosted by
French comedians internet celebrities
and content creators and they had some
pretty big names on their program like
not so big that you've probably heard of
them because you know they're French and
our analytics say that you're not but
there was a youtuber with over 13
million subs a former Canal+ TV host and
the former Miss France for some reason
so they're combining big names with a
consistent streaming schedule it seems
pretty straightforward right like it's
not a guaranteed formula for twitch it
says nobody was staring at a wall for 7
hours but it seems like a pretty smart
play from a media company trying to get
a broader audience on Twitch they
launched on February 3rd and they lasted
like five whole minutes before things
started to go wrong YouTube money
which tends to ban people who use racial
slurs on a live stream but that's not
the only thing that happened they had
some pretty weird audio issues and they
really really bizarre Hitler go look I
don't think making a bad Hitler joke is
a reason to get banned if it was a
reason they got banned at all but I do
want to take a moment to highlight just
how bad this joke is like it's not
offensive at all it's just not a joke
they asked her for a wrong answer and
she gave one I have no idea what's
supposed to be funny about it
okay anyway for some context French
comedy tends to be uh let's say edgier
than were used to in North America
that's not to say that it makes things
like using racial slurs okay but it does
mean that it makes sense that a French
company might not see that as
necessarily leading to an immediate ban
apparently in France they just think
that only Americans are offended by the
n-word and if you want some evidence of
that the French newspaper la Parisienne
wrote an article about this whole thing
and they drop the n-bomb twice trying to
explain the situation to their audience
then they translated it as quote one of
the most taboo phrases in the American
vocabulary oh [ __ ] anyway generally
speaking people really didn't seem happy
with the show's offerings apparently
people were throwing up resident
sleepers in the chat over on their
YouTube stream even people outside of
France noticed this whole mess a post on
live stream fails got huge and people
were losing their minds about how
[ __ ] dumb it was no Parisienne that
French newspaper I mentioned earlier
reached out to obedia the company behind
this whole show and they said that the
whole situation was quote far from
perfect which yeah obviously they
actually said at the time that they
weren't sure why they got banned and
they went on to say that the whole
situation it's really complicated to
manage so many streams on different
platforms and listen I don't want to
judge I don't think that that's the part
that anyone thought was not complicated
I think the part that's not complicated
is keeping your talent from using racial
slurs on a live broadcast anyway their
twitch channel is actually back now
though they don't store any BOTS so the
only thing left from their disaster of a
launch is clips people reupload it to
Twitter and what this kind of stuff does
happen all the time people do and say
things they really aren't supposed to
they get banned they come back dock went
into a bathroom
amaranth had a wardrobe malfunction help
say the kiss got banned for using the
exact same word that the dude on this
stream did but there is a big difference
here those people are all individuals
they know that sometimes they'll [ __ ] up
you know what out of control and it's
gonna suck for them but they can bounce
back this show will live it's part of a
massive media company web media runs a
ton of huge websites in France and this
was supposed to be a big break into
twitch for them the launch going this
battle II shot the whole thing in the
foot it's not the kind of thing you can
just bounce back from making a comeback
after being banned just hours after
starting your stream is the kind of
thing that an edgy streamer with a
strong personality can pull off but it's
gonna be a hell of a lot harder for some
faceless company that no one necessarily
cares about
did you guys hear they're making the
apex TV show during the office what how
Scientology took over neopets is not a
sense I thought I would hear at 11
o'clock on a Monday or Tuesday from the
outline Neopets quiet relationship with
Scientology Neopets was run by
Scientologists executives even suggested
adding religious principles of the game
wow my whole childhood has been distant
like completely shifted was I being
brainwashed by Scientologists I didn't
play much Neopets I probably play I
probably like mess around with it for a
month I have to check in on my
it was very popular like my middle
school I have to check in on my
girlfriend cuz she was a huge Neopets
fan and she may just be like secretly
praising Xenu yeah I've gotta like pull
out the four boards